the judge and an NFL player's rape trial
questions a jury member about what they
heard through the grapevine about the
case we would ask to do excuses juror as
emotional Witnesses take the stand to
recount what the victim told them the
night of the alleged crime she said that
Josh raped her
our legal analysts take a deep dive into
what we learned from the Ohio courtroom
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everybody to Long Prime daily
I'm Jesse Weber Witnesses who were
nearby the night a woman says a
professional football player raped her
testified in an Ohio courtroom about
what the victim revealed right after the
alleged crime Josh Sills an offensive
lineman with the Philadelphia Eagles was
indicted earlier this year on one count
of rape and another count of kidnapping
the victim sometimes referred to during
the trial as mm told police in 2019 that
Sills was giving her and her cousin a
ride home after a night out the victim
said that she'd known Sills for several
years and they even went to high school
together she told police that when her
cousin got out Sills pulled her back
into the truck with him and forced her
to perform oral sex before eventually
letting her go Sills and his defense
teams say that that sex was consensual
the victim testified Tuesday about what
happened to her but chose not to have
her voice or image recorded on camera
on Wednesday one of the friends who was
out with the group that night was
emotional as she described what mm told
her when she got inside the house
she said that Josh raped her okay who
was she referring to Josh Sills he was
the individual that was with you guys
that night yes she said when I pulled up
in the driveway
he held her down on him
on his penis and she couldn't breathe
and she tried hard to fight back
um
and she said that he tried to unzip her
pants and
physically sexually assault her
the other way vaginally but she got away
she said she had some strengths that
came over top of her and she got out of
the truck
and then she showed me the marks from
where his hands had was holding her down
on her legs on her inner thighs
okay let me bring in my legal analysts
and co-host Brian buckmeyer Terry Austin
Terry I'll start with you you know it's
one thing for the victim to testify it's
another thing for someone else to
testify about what the victim told her
how impactful is that testimony she was
very impactful she cried she seemed very
credible to me and the best part about
her testimony as far as the victim is
concerned is everything happened at the
same time on that night she learned of
the rape the day it happened the alleged
rape obviously so I think this is very
different from other cases this is a
case where it's not just he said she
said this is a case where you have a
witness who's there the same night and
who is testifying on behalf of the
victim I think that is going to go far
as far as this jury is concerned if they
can show the injuries Brian match up to
her account is that a conviction right
there I think it is that's corroboration
it's not just an issue of is this victim
credible or this alleged victim credible
is the good friend that she outcry to
also credible but now you have one story
story two-story and physical evidence to
corroborate it I think it's very hard
for sales to get up there and argue
anything else the question being why
does she have these injuries and why are
they proven if this was consensual sex
and I know there's always that
allegation of rough sex gone bad I mean
we'll see if that's where they go he
says it was consensual what's an outcry
witness because we were just taught we
were just referring to that an outcry
witness is someone who's coming out and
saying you know exactly what happened
this is the person who was the victim's
friend who's coming out and saying
exactly what she saw that night she's an
eyewitness to what exactly happened and
one of the things that I think about
this case is the defense is definitely
going to try to claim that this was
consensual but I think also the defense
is claiming that being the witness here
was you know drinking along with
everyone else Bing was underage but
saying that the victim was someone who
was drinking does this mean he has to
take the stand I think he does I mean
who else is going to be able to get up
on the stand and say this was consensual
other than the two people inside of the
car and I don't think it's going to be
alleged victim I think it's got to be
Sills and so it really does become a he
said she said in this kind of case
difficult difficult these cases are
always so difficult and a lot of times
it really does come down to who the jury
believes in terms of the testimony and
still had a long crime daily Court was
on hold in the Sills trial this morning
as the judge addressed a juror issue
what the juror heard the night before
that could have an impact on her
judgment and what the judge ultimately
decided to do what's next
long crime network is searching the
country for the best detective in the
United States we're looking for the top
investigators who helped to solve the
nation's most high profile cases from
medical examiners to forensic experts or
even private eyes if you or someone you
know believes they're one of America's
greatest detectives submit your
applications now the top three
detectives will be featured on our
social media and the winner given a five
thousand dollar prize go to
lawncrime.com
detective to submit your nomination
[Music]
and welcome back to Long Prime daily
everybody we are continuing our coverage
of Josh Sills rape trial out in Ohio
early Wednesday morning the court spent
around 15 minutes dealing with a very
serious jury issue you see one of the
jurors contacted a bell if letting the
court know that she had a phone call
from a friend who had overheard defense
attorneys talking while they were out to
dinner Tuesday night now while the
defense thought the judge should replace
her with an alternate the prosecution
was fine with keeping her on the juror
explained to the judge and lawyers how
she was contacted
a friend of mine had called me
and she works at the Forum
and she
was telling me
that the defense
Counsel had went to the Forum for dinner
and were talking about her friend's case
loud enough that the other employees
could hear
them talking and they knew who they were
talking about
and all the
co-workers were upset and I said I can't
talk about the case I'm on the jury
and she said okay we would ask that you
excuses juror for uh the fact that she
has received information outside of the
testimony in this case that she has
learned that the folks at the restaurant
were offended by our conversations as
well as that information she provided
which would be part of perhaps an
argument as to uh as to the
circumstances surrounding the assault so
I think that that's as serious enough of
series of events that would warrant her
in order to protect the
the the jury itself to have an alternate
sit in her place on the road she
indicated that this didn't impact her
opinion on the case we haven't seen so
far
what do you think juror saying she
received a phone call about the
attorneys talking is that too
prejudicial jurs shouldn't be seated
anymore
I didn't like necessarily the defense's
argument I think they could have gone a
little bit harder on the idea that this
juror got a phone call that aggravated
at least her friend that the kids go out
together they hang out together so much
so that they called her and let her know
it's not about information outside of
the case it's about how she feels about
us now if I as a defense attorney have
now tainted this case to the point that
my client can get a fair trial you've
got to let her go and I think as an
appellate court might lean that way and
toss this case out where otherwise seems
pretty strong for the prosecution that's
the defense's argument that's the
defense attorney and Brian buckmar what
do you think Terry well you know did the
judge make the right decision I have
make feelings I at first thought she
should be tossed but I think the Judge
did make the right decision listen the
defense should not have been in that
restaurant speaking so loudly that
everyone in the restaurant could hear
what they were saying and frankly it's a
small community and they should have
understood that someone at that
restaurant might know one of the jurors
and in fact they knew the person
absolutely the victim and they didn't
like the conversation and they called
the juror and I just think that you know
when she the juror found out she
immediately contacted the judge and she
said to the person who called her don't
speak to me so I think she did exactly
what the judge asked her to do so for
those reasons I think she could stay
well let me ask you this you said the
appeal if he gets convicted how do you
show that that incident is what
prejudiced the jury to vote against
Sills I'm asking each and every juror
except for that one juror that got the
call what was your impression of her
when when someone said X about a piece
of evidence and she said why or even X
about something what do you think of the
juror yeah okay when when when when
someone said ask about what I the
defense attorney said and she said why
did it always come back like it she
seems she had a negative issue about me
the defense attorney rather than the
case and by surveying the jury if that
comes positive yeah that's ammunition
for an appeal real quick Terry should
this have been a mistrial I don't think
definitely not not a mistrial she
shouldn't have been bumped off I think
the Judge did make the right decision
she should say she said she could be
fair that's right I think you're right
if he is convicted that is going in the
ammunition books as a potential
appellate issue not sure it'll be
successful but definitely an argument